and there's the young man his second big
league start the first one we detailed
4.20 era and 14 starts
in the minors who could be a big part of
this rotation coming down the stretch
driven out into right center field davis
on the run still going back and he makes
the play oh did he cover a lot of ground
to haul that in
swing and a miss hannigan
down on strikes
[Applause]
and a blanket of strikes as seeger
strikes out kikuchi will get the start
his 21st start on the year seven and six
record at 389 era
tagged by raleigh down goes lemay he
went out
that's hit hard sager gobbles it up
throws over in time two down what a play
and gala walks
nice play by seeger great play well done
the o2
swing and a miss as france down on
strikes and heel has struck out three in
a row
and that's going to get down base hit
for jared kelnick
cal pulls it
fielded by voight and throws it away
nobody is there kelnick is on the horse
and he'll get the third as gallow throws
it back into second anders will take
that 3-1 pitch to jake
and that'll load him up
straight three
he got it with the slider moore thought
it was ball four
but lance barrett thought otherwise
strikeout number four for heel two-way
grounded to first boy
beats into the bag
and they get out of trouble
an impressive performance by heal
just got called up to replace
anthony rizzo who won on the covet il
22 home runs last year in the 60 game
covered shortened season and that led
all of major league baseball
that one is ripped to left field
it's a base hit and it gets past fairly
and goes to the wall
torres is going for two and he's gonna
make it
and he serves that one fraley on the
case
greatly reading it right away pretty
good break you see it slicing away from
him
the delivery super mow as he makes the
catch and goes into the slide
and
drills this from straight away center
field kellnick looking for it oh that's
a fine fine reaction by the rookie jared
kellnick
boy he hung with that beautifully well
done saves a run
and there's a rocket off the bat of
mitch haniger
joey gallo gets it back in
seeger swings and misses and goes down
on strikes for the second time against
heal crowd wants a strikeout
crowd gets it kel nick down looking
six strikeout for heel
line drive a base hit to right center
field
helmet will get the ball in and lemayo
picks up a one out single
and a walk
so first and second one man out for
gallow
cacucci deal swinging him struck him out
big one
and that hits stanton and that'll load
the bases for voight
2-2
did he go did he go yes he did
there's a break
line into right center field it's a base
hit
cutting over his bowers
and torres with a lead-off single here
in the fourth inning
and he's going to make it
like flavor torres hurt his hand going
into second base but a great
kind of a cheat steal there just taking
off on kikuchi look like that hand hit
the bag too hard and now the yankee's
gonna come out and take a look
now there it's the left hand and he's
feeling that the trainer is
as tim london just seeing if there's
if he can move his hand if the bone is
okay
shaking his head okay i'm okay
swing and a miss
strikeout number eight for heel
grounded and backhanded by taurus the
throat of first they got it
so he has retired seven in a row one two
three fifth inning second yankee all
time
to not allow a run
in the first two major league starts the
other one slow joe doyle
slow joe 1906 that's a while ago
and he does it
and the mariners will take it
joey galla wants a single we'll give him
a single keep him out of the right field
porch
and there's a walk to stanton
two balls two strikes to voight
popped it up
long run bowers coming on foul territory
that'll be ty france
casey this will be his 20th appearance
opponents hitting just over 200 against
him
and how about torrez he's three for
three today
a couple of singles and a double he
leads off with a single here in the
sixth
and elder
gets hit on the foot and he's going to
take first base he had squared to bunt
paul seawall 35 appearances opponents
hitting just 169 against him
2-2 pitch got him to chase that breaking
ball down and in
swinging a miss got him paul seawall
gave up a three-run homer a couple of
nights ago to joey gallo comes up large
right here with a couple of men aboard
no score
and steven writings pitching his third
big league game
swing and a miss
99 miles an hour
swing and a miss
[Applause]
sounds like he wanted that strikeout
it's in the triangle judge oh my
goodness no wave it off tim timmon said
nope
how about tim tim it's a great position
yeah he's standing right out there here
he comes yep did it hit the ground yep
warner goes again swing and a miss
filthy slider and writings rings up
three more strikeouts
big two-two pitch seawall to judge
struck him out great job by paul seawall
boy that's big time
strikeout paul seawall four up four down
via the strikeout all swinging
breaking ball hit down to third odor
can't handle it adore
miss play allows toro
to reach
there you go
a couple of base runners here
for kyle seeger
one for three base hit his last time up
swing and a drive right field
off the glove of judging into the stands
scoring is
toro and the mariners have a one-nothing
lead brown rolled double hanniga to
third
seeger to second rbi for kyle is 71st
strike three kellnick down looking
got him on the slider
and the rookie barking at the home plate
umpire
hardly see a rookie ever react like that
but he did just gonna come out and talk
with barrett but i'll tell you what
kellnick in the third and we threw him
out was barking and barking scott and
the ball club having some issues with
the home plate umpires especially the
last couple of ball games
and now scott service has just been
tossed from this game
there we go and two to cal
[Applause]
line drive based hit
hannigger scores
seger coming around he's in there
a two-run single by cal rally and
americans have a three nothing lead in
the eighth
big two out knocked by the rookie looks
like the yankees are calling for a
challenge of that play at home plate
they might win that paul i'm not quite
sure but looks like they got him on the
chest before he hit the bag
and he's out
good challenge
good overturn
rather economical one two three eighth
inning the one-two pitch strike three
called getting game over